Well,
I've been,
I've been really fascinated by the life that you guys live in Hawaii,
that you,
it's because I've always had this like idealized,
I like one day like move to the big island,
just chill on the side of a mountain,
stop fucking around,
fly out to do gigs,
but live out there where everything's just more relaxed,
you know?
Is it okay?
You know,
there's a lot going on and like the Big island is obviously big city.
Yeah.
No one's been,
not the big island has,
it's sort of like la on the beach.
But yeah.
You know,
there's a couple things I think because it is a primal environment.
Like we live on Kauai,
which is PR,
pretty heavy duty as far as,
um,
it's quiet.
There's not a lot of distraction.
There's a really heavy duty nature.
And,
um,
and so I,
and I grew up in,
in St Thomas on the Virgin Islands,
so I was used to kind of being on an island.
But you're,
you're with yourself a lot.
So if you have things to do that are,
you know,
productive,
then it's perfect.
Um,
but what you have to always calibrate is like,
um,
the downtime or it like,
it's been raining off and on for like over a year on Hawaii.
Whoa.
Yeah.
So after a while it'd be like Seattle in that way where people,
it starts getting heavy,
but it's sunny too,
right?
It can be,
and it's the weirdest thing about the islands.
Yeah.
There's different climates on this island.
The Big island has desert.
Yes.
Tropical rain forest is a volcano is all this shit.
Every,
I think it has every,
uh,
weather,
um,
climate.
Except Arctic,
I believe at least Maui and the big island have sort of every type of climate.
It's crazy that just a little bit further down and it'll be different.
It'll be raining constantly.
Yeah,
exactly.
Or You just go to the other side and it's completely dry.
Or they have dwarf trees because they never see the sun,
but then they're,
you know,
200 feet in the places that it's sunny.
It's,
it's pretty trippy.
And you could drive around the whole thing and like how many hours does it take
you to drive on the Big Island?
Oh,
the big island,
I don't know,
like four hours or something like that thing.
I think so.
Maybe a little more.
Yeah.
You like the big island.
Interesting.
I like Maui.
You do every islands different.
They're all,
their personalities are different,
but I like it.
I mean we've been doing this for over 23 years.
When I met Laird,
he was big waves sort of come in winter.
So when low pressures bring snow,
like to the rest of the mainland,
that low pressure can also bring big waves.
And then my season was summer,
so we sort of went back and forth.
And that's a really good blend because you,
you can come to California and be like,
oh,
it's a busy world.
I can see a lot of people.
I can learn stuff,
I can do stuff.
Um,
and then I also makes you appreciate when you go back to Hawaii or like clean
air,
really clean water,
very beautiful place.
Um,
some of the ways,
the ideas about the,
they live there,
it's,
it's simple in a good way.
I don't mean that in any way.
Like a derogatory,
it's like they're not trying to,
they're not angling and trying to get somewhere.
It's like,
no,
we're living right.
Um,
but it can be also a very,
a really hard place,
really hard place.
So,
well I think,
you know,
and you're also talking about a warrior culture,
right?
Polynesians.
So you have like this,
this very intense love.
And uh,
you know,
when they talk about the Aloha spirit generosity,
they have like this and then they're very powerful people as well.
And sometimes if they're not living as they're in their most natural way that
they were supposed to,
and then you couple it with,
um,
you know,
there's not a ton of opportunities there.
It's hard to live there.
It's far away.
It's expensive.
Um,
and,
and sometimes,
you know,
it sounds Cliche,
but it's like we really do as human organisms either need to be busy,
so like,
okay,
working from sunup to sundown for our food,
which is how it used to be,
and then you're just so tired,
you just go to bed and it's pretty simple and deal.
Let's just survive it.
Or in the world that we live in now,
it's like,
how do we get people doing things that are kind of productive and you think,
oh,
I just would sit on the beach and look at the mountain.
And it's like,
yeah,
and after a while you get bored.
And if you're a warrior,
you're either gonna go,
you know,
do something with that that is good for you or you might not.
So,
um,
I think there's,
there's a lot,
a lot of that there.
I've learned a lot from that culture.
Um,
but I mean,
they're pretty powerful.
They're powerful group and,
uh,
you know,
it can go the other way pretty quick where it's,
if there's drugs and alcohol are beefing and like it's all that.
So it's,
that was really disturbing and found out how much drug abuse throughs on some of
the islands.
Yeah.
Crystal Mathis especially sad.
Well,
it's,
again,
it goes back to board and like,
think about when your kids have to stay home for one day.
Yep.
You know,
it's just,
and now we have all these,
the internet and all this stuff.
So now you've got your sort of think,
oh,
the rest of the world has a perfect,
they're all busy and doing fabulous,
perfect things.
And um,
and it's hard.
Like you got to find people that you're like,
let's do something.
Let's go.
I mean,
can you train alone every single time now?
So you'd have to have a tribe of people that are like,
let's go do this activity.
And sometimes they don't.
It's not that easy.
Well,
so there's,
there's just say there's 70,000 people on the island.
Uncle [inaudible] is probably the least,
uh,
inhabited,
it's the oldest island,
so it has the most erosion,
largest beaches.
Um,
and that's where Larry grew up.
And it's a,
it's a,
it's a really nice,
the loose habitat on the islands,
isn't it?
Well,
yeah.
I mean it's not that I don't count it.
Yeah.
I mean,
of the bigger islands.
Yeah.
Malkai man,
you wouldn't,
you don't,
you don't mess with Malkai.
No,
no.
That's like,
that's like you,
you got to ask permission to go hang out over there.
Kinda.
Yeah.
It's cool though cause it's like if you know,
if they'd be like,
no,
you gotta,
you can't,
you're out.
You've got to go.
Really.
Totally.
So is great.
Is the people that live there,
you can't like move to Molokai?
Yeah.
I mean like you know,
I,
Eddie Vedder has a place on Molokai.
Yep.
And he has had for many,
many years,
but I think he probably asked if that was going to be cool.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
Interesting.
It's,
and it's beautiful.
You have some friends that just went hunting there.
Yeah.
Beautiful access to your,
yeah.
Yeah.
It's a beautiful place and the people are amazing,
but you,
you,
it's not like,
oh,
I'm just going to buy a house there or build a house.
There's no way.
No Way.
Wow.
That's interesting that you,
all these different islands have their own like rules.
Well neo is a,
you can't even,
you can't go there.
You're not even allowed to go.
No,
I didn't even know that was an island.
Yeah,
it's off of [inaudible].
Yeah.
It's skipper that Jamie's big fan of.
He looks like he's been to he house now,
that it's all,
but like they probably have the,
you know,
the largest percentage of pure of Hawaiians there.
So it's cool.
I mean,
pretty good.
It's gotta be a great,
like I've found that like,
there's a big difference between the,
the,
the culture of say Maui versus the culture of Lanai.
Lanai is more island d to me,
whereas Maui seems like little bit gentrified.
We'll also,
the wind cause it Maui so windy,
it brought all the Europeans in the 80s to wind surf.
So you're also have not only mainland us and then Japanese,
um,
culture,
you know,
eighties now you're talking about Europeans for wind and wind surfing.
So it has a lot going on.
I think Maui,
it was almost like a surprise how quick it developed and they never had a chance
to get on top of it,
if that makes sense.
It does make sense.
Yeah.